yep went online 15 hours before its
scheduled launch a sign of how eager
matters Mark Zuckerberg is to challenge
Twitter
and by association Twitter's owner
fellow billionaire Elon Musk creating a
new social media platform has long been
Zuckerberg's pet project if this is the
future that you want to see then I hope
that you will join us because the future
is going to be beyond anything we can
imagine threads is linked to Instagram
and closely resembles Twitter however
tweets are called threads and retweets
are called reposts posts on threads can
be 500 characters long as compared to
280 for most Twitter users I think
threads is going to pose a huge threat
to Twitter uh because it's coming from
The Meta and Instagram family of apps
Instagram has two billion users compared
to around 250 million uh of Twitter so
it's about 10 times bigger already so if
only one in 10 Instagram users tries
using threads it's overtaken Twitter in
the blink of an eye many analysts see
Twitter as vulnerable to competition
particularly in the light of the
controversial changes to the platform
introduced by Elon Musk since he took
over the company last year the only
other thing I would add is that's going
to be an interesting point in the next
24 48 hours is going to be Elon musk's
reaction and response to this threat
that has now become very immediate the
introduction of what some describe as a
Twitter killer signals the beginning of
a battle of big Tech and a potential
Showdown down between two big
personalities
Mike Hanna Al Jazeera Washington well
let's bring in Alfred Hamida he's a